on a tellement je vois travaux longs
bordés et monsieur gaudin berthet mais
c'est pas le poids devant le président
sortant le président sortant va
l'emporter
maintenant qu'est ce qui va se passer à
partir du 1er novembre
est-ce que l'opposition voit reconnaître
les élections qui ont eu lieu
est ce que les nouveaux riches à ne pas
former son gouvernement aussi est ce que
n'a pas estimé que le mandat de monsieur
ouattara plus fait sensation la question
que l'on se pose le moment 1 2010 déjà y
avait deux armées ceric dirigée par
monsieur sur le cube qui avait d amener
gay et qui dirigeait une bonne partie du
territoire national et celle du sud
auront beaucoup babeau présentement il
ya eu c'est l'armée c'est vrai qu'il ya
des opposants qui résonnent des trente
ans dans les rues pour essayer de
manifester mais c'est à peine et des
pieds qui ramasse les rues poussé lui ai
lancé sur les policiers c'est par le
rapport de force donc je ne pense pas
qu'on aura lé même je lance 2010 non je
ne pense pas